- Hello, and welcome to Ed
Talks with Khan Academy.
I'm Kristen DiCerbo, the
chief learning officer
at Khan Academy and I am excited today
to talk to Dr. Matt Townsley,
who is a professor and author
of "Making Grades Matter."
And we'll be talking
about all things grading,
so if you have questions,
please drop them into the chat.
I wanna remind you before
we start that Khan Academy
is a nonprofit organization
and we're able to do our work
thanks to donations from folks like you.
If you go to Khanacademy.org/donate,
you'll find a place where
you can make that donation
and help us keep doing that work.
So thank you so much
if you're able to give.
I also wanna recognize our corporate folks
who have helped support
us in the times of COVID,
including AT&T, General Motors and Fastly.
Next, if you want to listen
to this broadcast again,
or find previous broadcasts and have ways
to listen to those when you're
at the gym, on your walk
or otherwise listening to audio,
you can find them at Homeroom
with Sal, the podcast.
We look forward to seeing you there.
So as I said, I'm excited
today to welcome Matt Townsley.
He is the author of "Making Grades Matter,
"Standards-Based Grading
in a Secondary PLC."
So I'm looking forward to
talking about all things grading.
Welcome!
- Well, hello, thank you
very much for having me.
- Absolutely.
So, I always like to first ask people,
how did you end up studying
grading and grades?
What was your path to get here?
- Yeah, that's a really fun question,
and one I'm really excited
and passionate about.
I don't think I went into education,
I don't think anyone
really went into education
to get better at grading.
In fact, it might just be
something that we all have to do.
Although in 2008, I was a
high school math teacher
here in Iowa, and I went
to the state math teacher conference,
and there was a breakout session.
It was called how to fix
your broken grade book
led by another high school math teacher.
And I thought, "Well, I'll just go
"and see if I can take something away
"back to my own classroom
and get a little bit better."
Kristen, literally that
45 to 50 minute session
changed my professional career forever.
I came back really excited,
talked to our high school
principal at the time
and just thanked him for
allowing me to go back in 2008.
And he just really encouraged me to say,
"Hey, could you try out
something that you learned
"from this session in your class?"
And I thought, "Well,
there's only nine weeks
"left in the school year.
"That seems kind of crazy."
But I picked my last period geometry class
and just started changing some
things up related to grading.
And as a result of that, I started reading
every book or article or blog post
I could find about grading.
Fast forward a couple years later,
I had a number of conversations
with other teachers
in our high school and our middle school,
and they started thinking
differently about grading.
Fast forward another year or so later,
and I got promoted to the district office
and we had this dilemma in
our school in Solon, Iowa,
this little rural community in Iowa,
where some of our teachers
were thinking differently
about grading and others weren't yet.
And so we had a decision to make,
were we going to kind of be
okay with that middle ground,
or were we going to go on a journey to see
if we all wanted to think
about grading differently.
So obviously we made that to decision
to all think about grading differently,
and so my experience comes
from being a classroom teacher,
doing this standards-based grading thing,
and also leading a change
in our school district
to make grading practices
significantly different.
You mentioned our books,
"Making Grades Matter."
And again, as a high school math teacher,
I don't really consider
myself to be an author
or really that great of a writer,
but through others that have written books
and heard about our work,
we're actually encouraged
to write our own book, and so
in standards-based grading,
it's not always viewed
as something that is
easily attainable at the
secondary level, in particular.
And so our book really helps
middle school and high school teachers
take their next steps with
standards-based grading.
So that a little bit about my journey.
Currently though, I work at
the University of Northern Iowa
where I teach future
principals and superintendents,
and then also support as
many educators as possible
to take their next steps
towards more effective grading practices.
And it's just a thrill to be here today
talk about a topic I'm really, really,
really passionate about.
- That is great.
So let's start at the beginning.
What is standards-based grading?
- Yeah, great.
Maybe the best way to explain it is
it's a philosophy or a
process or a set of practices
that really aim to communicate
students current levels of learning
separately from their behaviors.
When you think about maybe
the grading practices
that you and I experienced as a student,
maybe we got like a 95% in a class,
but that 95% could have mean
we got 95% of the points
or it could have meant we
actually got 100% of the points
and turned in a couple assignments late,
and so maybe in the past,
we've mixed kind of
behaviors with learning.
In standards-based grading,
those two things are separate.
And I think about when I
take my car to a mechanic,
sometimes I do a 20-point inspection,
and on that 20-point inspection,
it tells me if my brakes are
really good or not very good,
if my battery is really
good or not very good,
and so the mechanic kind of breaks down
the components of my vehicle and gives me
very specific feedback on
how well my car is doing
in each one of those,
and so that's the aim
of standards-based grading,
is really just to give
our students a much more
detailed perspective
on a standard-by-standard
basis, if you will,
on what they're doing really well at
and what they could get even better at.
And also embeds elements
of probably something I know
you're very passionate about,
mastery learning as well,
and I hope we can talk
more about that today.
- That's great.
So from a student perspective,
what are the benefits of grading this way,
as opposed to a more traditional way?
- Yeah, so maybe in the past
students have found themselves
not really knowing what the
currency of the classroom is.
Sometimes it's just all about earning
when they're at that cusp of 89.4%
and they want to get their
grade up to an 89.5%,
so it'll get rounded up to
the favorable grade they want
to get the scholarship or the honor roll
or the GPA that they want.
They may just ask the teacher,
"What can I do to improve my grade?"
And maybe the teacher is
in a good mood that day
and says, "Here's a extra
credit crossword puzzle,"
or "Here's something else you can do,"
but maybe the teacher's
not in that great of a mood
or just maybe has more of a, hey, you need
to just do better next time mindset
because the currency of the
classroom is all about earning
at that point.
When the currency of the classroom,
which is what standards-based
grading is all about,
is more about learning,
now, a student might ask,
"Hey, Mr. Townsley, I'm not very good yet
"at Pythagorean's Theorem.
"Could I show you
"how I'm better at
Pythagorean's Theorem now?"
And by showing me as the teacher,
that they're actually better
at Pythagorean's Theorem,
then as a result of that,
their grade might improve,
which is a good thing, right,
because if a student has
learned more of the math stuff
or the science stuff or
the social studies stuff.
They should of course have a better grade
because the purpose of grades
is really to communicate students'
current levels of learning.
So students really, I believe, are more,
they have more ownership
in the learning process
because it's more about what's
what they're in control of,
which is the extent to
which they've learned
the standards in the class.
- Got it.
So I see that link.
So as we think about
mastery learning here,
one of the things that
we're thinking about is
that you're doing whatever
the work you need is
to increase your proficiency
or work towards mastering.
It's not that you get one shot at a test
and that's your score,
but you can keep learning and keep trying
and improving on that over time.
Does that fit in then to this idea
of grading based on standards?
- Yes, indeed, it does.
And in my own research,
I've read quite a bit
about mastery learning,
so I can confirm this
on that level, Kristin.
As I think back to mastery learning,
I think of Benjamin Bloom and others
that have really set the foundation
for what mastery learning is.
And back in the day,
there was this mentality
of, well only a certain
percent of the students
ought to deserve an A or only
a certain element of students
ought to be successful in the class,
kind of that bell shaped
curve, IQ testing mentality.
But when Bloom others really
challenged that mindset,
they said, "You know what?
"If we provide students more
time and the right conditions,
"many, many, many, many more students
"can learn at a high level."
In other words, if
achievement can be constant
and time can become the variable,
then even more students
can learn at a high level.
And as I think about
standards-based grading,
that's really what it aim to do.
As I think about the
grading practices, again,
that maybe you and I experienced
back in the day, Kristen,
if we did not do very
well kind of early on
in the learning process,
maybe we turned in
some homework assignments that
we didn't really understand
what was going on in our class,
we kind of dug ourselves into a hole
point-wise or percentage-wise.
Within a standards-based grading mindset,
it's really all about how
much has a student learned,
and if Kristen, if you or
I are in the same class
and you may learn it before I do,
one of the premises of
standards-based grading
is it doesn't really matter
when a student learns it.
We honor the fact that students learn
at different rates and different paces.
And if my learning comes later,
I'm gonna erase that
old version of learning
in the grade book, and
I'm gonna replace it
with more recent evidence of learning.
And again, that's maybe a
mindset shift in particular
for many of our secondary
educators out there,
but it really comes.
It's not necessarily a new idea.
It comes from years and
years and years of theory
and research related to mastery learning.
I think Leanne Young and Tom
Gusty in their 2011 article
in the Clearinghouse really
made some strong connections
between mastery learning
and also the response
to intervention model that many schools
are working towards right now
that just says, "Hey, you know what?
"If we could really provide
quality instruction,
"if we can also then
provide the right amount
"of interventions to students who still
"do not yet understand it, we
could help a lot of students
"learn at a high level."
And all of those things really fit in
the standards-based grading
and mastery learning bucket,
if you will.
- That totally makes sense.
And this also is reminding me of links
to motivation research, where there's,
whether students are motivated to learn,
or whether they're
motivated to get a score
that shows what they learn
and that students who are
motivated based on learning a new thing
tend to be more engaged and
more interested in learning.
Is that connected to all of this, as well,
in terms of increasing student motivation?
- Of course, yes.
Again, as I think about
the default feedback
that I included, that I gave to students
back in the day before I went to this
state math teacher conference,
I would frequently give
students like a 14 outta a 16
on a quiz, but that 14 out of 16
really didn't tell the student
what they're doing really well at
and what they need to get better at.
I mean, imagine if I went
to the doctor's office,
the doctor's office said,
"You're about a 85% health."
I'd be like, "Well,
what's the other 15%, doc?
"Tell me, tell me, tell me!"
And so at the heart of
standards-based grading is using
some other type of scale.
Many schools have used an almost,
or a proficient or some
other descriptor of learning
to tell a student exactly
the extent to which they have
learned that particular standard.
And really what it is, it's
much more specific feedback
to the student on exactly
what they're doing
and what they need to do to get better.
One of the things that I look back
on in my own teaching career and wonder is
how often was I giving
feedback to students
that really helped them
understand how to close the gap.
And so sometimes when
educators start doing this
standards-based grading thing,
they realize that it's
not just the grade book
that needs to improve,
but it's also their feedback practices.
And if I could just give a
shout out to so many wonderful
researchers and authors out there,
Susan Brookhart, Dylan William, and others
that have really talked about
feedback being at the heart
of the learning process
and our students really deserve feedback,
not on a unit three test or
in just an essay perspective,
but on a much more granular level,
on a standard-by-standard level.
And we provide 'em that very
detailed level of feedback,
you're right, Kristen.
The research suggests
they're much more excited,
motivated to improve upon that feedback.
- That makes sense.
So you said this could be a
change in thinking and mindset
for some educators in where things are.
What are some things that,
for instance, when you came
back from this conference,
what are maybe some initial
steps that teachers can take
towards this different mindset?
- Yeah, a couple things.
One is, in my mind I tend
to think about textbooks
and chapters as being the
driving force for what I taught.
In fact, I'll never forget
when got my first teaching job,
I was assigned to teach geometry
and several other courses.
And I asked some of
their teachers and said,
"Hey, what are kids supposed
to learn in geometry?"
And they said, "Well, here's the textbook.
"Most years we get to chapter 12
"and some years we get to chapter 13.
"Here you go."
And so of course that's what I did,
but now what I know is you most states
have some list of state standards, right?
There have been some people
that have gotten together
and said these are the
most important things
that students are supposed
to learn in biology
or algebra one or seventh grade science.
And so instead of thinking
about the textbook
being the driving force in what we teach,
we should look at the standards.
I worked with some PE teachers
even in our school district.
And they said, "Well, I was
just so used to always doing
"the volleyball unit or the
PE or the football unit,"
and frankly that's the way
they've always done it,
and so that's okay.
But we started thinking about what are
the specific learning goals.
What are the specific
standards that students
are supposed to be learning in PE
or seventh grade science or in math?
And so, instead of thinking
about the activities
and the units as being the driver,
we have to first start
thinking about the standards
or the learning goals being the driver.
And then secondly, we
have to design assessments
that are very well aligned
to those learning goals
or those standards.
Again, so many of us we've just inherited
the assessments, right?
The tests that come with
the textbook materials
or the tests or the
quizzes or the projects
that have been handed down
from one teacher to the next.
We have to ask ourselves
to what extent are those
actually aligned to the
learning goals that we want.
And then finally, if I'm thinking
about just a typical high
school or middle school teacher,
so many of us are used to grading
based upon points and percentages,
and points and percentages
don't really do the best job
of communicating to students
what they're really good at
and what they're not really good at.
I mean, think about this.
What's the difference between a student
who has 96% on a test and 94% on a test?
Is there some, is there a difference
that's actually describable?
Can we put our mind and our hands
and our fingers on what that
difference is in that 2%?
So when educators real
wrap their mind around
the standards-based grading
thing, they're going to,
instead of thinking about percentages,
they're going to think about
some levels of learning,
beginning, developing, area
of concern and proficient.
And again, that's just a huge
mind shift for so many of us,
not because we may not want to do it,
but because in our teacher
preparation programs,
we haven't necessarily been
taught how to do it yet.
And I'm confident as we
continue to improve and evolve
in our teacher preparation
and administrative preparation programs,
that in time we'll get to that point
where more educators will be
familiar with this process.
- Yeah, so that leads me to think
how much can a teacher
do this on their own,
versus how much do they
need the school support,
changing what the report cards look like,
changing what the parents
are expecting to come home
and where those are?
What's the balance between those?
- Oh, Kristen, you're giving
me some good flashbacks
to 2008, 2009 as myself and
just a few other teachers,
as we started doing it.
Frankly, Kristen, it was an uphill battle
for a number of years
because in our classrooms,
we were trying to reculture,
as I referred to earlier,
as the currency of our
classroom for students
being all about learning.
And again, this is not
because the other teachers
from our school were consciously doing it,
but that's just because
that's just what they knew.
And so students in my class,
I might've been the only teacher
that they had all day long,
where the currency of the
classroom was learning early on.
And so it takes a really passionate,
knowledgeable teacher
to say, "You know what?
"There's going to be some hiccups.
"There are going to be
some implementation dips
"along the way."
And one very specific one,
as we think about, again,
this idea of mastery
learning is that time becomes
the variable, not the constant.
We want achievement to be the constant.
So myself as a teacher,
I have to figure out
times during my class period
times during the school day
where I can provide additional
instruction to students
who have not yet
demonstrated an understanding
of Pythagorean's Theorem
or the other standards in the classroom.
And that's much easier when
the whole school is on board.
We'll hear about schools
doing an intervention time
or a what I need time,
or if their mascot is tiger a tiger time
where school-wide
students are provided time
for additional instruction
and reassessments.
If those specific times during
the day are not in place,
and if the culture of most classrooms
is still more about earning
than it is about learning,
for individual teachers,
this is going to be
a pretty big uphill battle.
And so that's why in our
book, "Making Grades Matter,"
we talk about the
individual classroom shifts
in many of our chapters
and we talk about doing it
as a team, as a professional
learning community together.
And then in the final chapter of our book,
we also talk about
specifically how to make
this entire shift as school.
And so in the research that I've done
and that I've seen, Kristen,
almost always, there is
a certain level of an
implementation dip that happens.
And it's most often because
we're not approaching it
as an entire school
and understanding that there
will be an implementation dip.
And so I appreciate that question.
So I wanna encourage listeners
and viewers out there
that are really thinking
about making the shifts
to know and appreciate
the implementation dip
and to ride it out and to
encourage our entire school
to make these changes in time.
And it really does take time.
- That totally makes sense.
So we have a couple
questions that are similar
to each other along the same line.
So one from Avive and
one from Lance McConnell.
So what are the things to
start to work with teachers
to help shift mindsets and Avive asks
if teachers have less flexibility,
what are some things that they can do,
again, a first couple of steps
to start changing their practice?
- Yeah, I'd say a couple things.
One is just to first take a
kind of a balcony view and say,
"What's the purpose of
grades in my classroom?"
Sometimes we'll kind of jump right down
to the actionable things
that a teacher should do.
And maybe instead of giving
zeros for incomplete work,
maybe just give fifties,
sometimes hear about schools doing that.
And while that's an admirable practice,
in absence of really focusing
on what's the purpose of grades,
oh, the purpose of grades
is to communicate learning.
So just having the
conversation with a department,
having a conversation with
an individual teacher,
having a conversation
at a faculty meeting,
like what do we believe
as a school or as a team
is the purpose of grading.
And then if, while we're
waiting for maybe everyone
to move forward in an actionable way
in some of the things I mentioned earlier,
individual teachers can
start doing what I call
having one foot in the
standards-based grading world,
and one foot in the
traditional grading world.
We can experiment with our students.
For example, at an upcoming test,
if you know as a teacher
that you cannot yet
put like a one, two, three or four
or a area of concern, beginning,
almost there, proficient
in the grade book yet,
you could still provide
that same level of feedback
to students on an upcoming test
for each standard or learning goal.
And just ask students, "Hey,
with this level of feedback,
"what do you want to do next?
"How can I help you as a teacher improve
"on these learning goals?
"What can you do as a student
"to improve on these learning goals?"
And you can have the conversation
without having to change anything
at all in the grade book.
Now, in that scenario, you would still put
whatever the building or
the district requires,
like a percentage in the grade book,
but you would have the
conversation with your students
to see how they would react
to a much more specific
learning goal feedback.
And I think what most educators will find
is that students actually crave
that same level of feedback.
One of the things I
did in my own classroom
is I started asking students
about the level of feedback they got
from their drama director
or their musical director,
or their band instructor,
or their football coach.
And most often all of those
extracurricular or co-curricular
sponsors and coaches gave
them very detailed feedback.
And so I think if we make that connection,
even if we can't be all
in in the grade book
because of building or
district policy constraints,
we can still begin to provide
that same level of feedback
to our students and see
how they react to it.
And what that's gonna require
is just taking a more precise
look at our assessments
and allowing them the standards.
And I think any teacher
can start doing that now
without having to have the permission
of their administration, or
have some switch turned on
at the electronic grade book
level to make that possible.
- Great.
Here's another question
from Facebook, Greg Mullin.
It's a little bit
different, but interesting.
How does standards-based grading
help prepare students
for higher education?
And I wonder if there's a
sub-question in there of like,
if I have good grades like this
are college is gonna
look at it kinda funny?
- Yeah, fun to hear some of these names
gonna turn out there, Kristen.
Thank you, Lance.
Thank you, Greg, for your questions.
So regarding your question here, Greg,
just a fantastic question.
One that is very important to discuss,
specifically for high
schools making the shift.
First, so often secondary
parents or secondary teachers
or secondary administrators will say,
"If we do this, is it really going
"to prepare students for college?"
First, a couple things.
First, most of the high
schools I know that do this,
they still eventually determine
a specific letter grade
from the standard marks in the grade book.
And so these high schools still have a GPA
that's still used for admissions
and scholarship decisions.
Now down in the weeds a little bit,
then a next question maybe
Greg's thinking about is,
but what if we provide students
these multiple opportunities?
What if we provide these redos and retakes
in the spirit of mastery learning,
they may or may not do
that at the college level?
Well, what we have to
know at the K12 level is
our aim, because of federal legislation,
such as No Child Left behind
and Every Student Succeeds Act,
our aim is to help as many
kids as possible get it,
like that's our job in the K12 world.
That may or may not be
what the university and
college folks are doing.
And again, as a college professor,
I can kind of speak to that
that there's just a
different paradigm sometimes
at the college university level.
So, regardless of what
college or universities do,
our aim in K12 is to help as
many kids as possible get it.
And so we believe that kids
learn at different rates
and different paces.
So of course then it makes
sense to provide students
multiple opportunities to
demonstrate their learning
through this whole reteaching
and reassessment process.
And finally, some research that I've done
with Dr. Thomas Guskey
and Dr. Thomas Buckmiller
suggests that college students
at the end of their first
semester, freshman year,
we actually went through
some surveys and interviews
of students who self-disclosed
that they went to a high
school that was doing this
standards-based grading stuff,
they shared with us in our
research that was published
towards the end of 2020 in
the NASSP Bulletin Journal
that they had just an okay
time adjusting to the college
and university level.
And so if we have this idea in our mind
that it's somehow going to
wreck them as they transition
to the college university,
our research suggests
that's just not the case, as well.
So thank you, Greg and others
for that wonderful, wonderful question.
- Excellent.
Lots of good questions coming in.
Here's another one thinking
about how does this apply
to gifted students?
- Fantastic, great, great, great.
- And I wonder if there's thoughts about,
yeah, does this create a ceiling that
prevents gifted students from maybe
moving into accelerated work or something?
- I think there's two facets
that are actually beneficial
to gifted education.
One of them is this.
I think about some students
I had in my own classroom
that were just high achievers
and I worked in a
high-achieving school district,
one of the most high-achieving
school districts
in the state of Iowa.
And there were some students
who, they were still required,
this was pre standards-based grading.
They were still required to do
the homework or the practice
because there was a point
value attached to it.
But they knew, their parents knew, I knew,
that they really didn't
need to do that practice,
and so it was just busy work for the sake
of getting points to get
the grade they wanted.
In a standards-based grading
philosophy or school,
there is no point value attached
to assignments that are intended to be
more practice-oriented.
So if I'm a gifted student,
now, I no longer am
subjected to doing busy work
for the sake of busy work to get points.
I think that's a huge win
for our gifted students
who may have other aspirations.
Secondly, in some schools, what
they will do is they'll say,
"Wow, this student based
upon this assessment
"evidence I have right
now is already proficient.
"They're already rocking and rolling
"with a specific standard,
and so I'm going to provide
"some level of extension
activity for this student."
Before we would not have had that same
detailed level of
information for the learner,
because prior to standards-based grading,
we would not have known by
the student, by the standard
who was our already getting it,
but with a standards-based
grading mentality and grade book
now we'll know specifically,
not just who the gifted students are,
but the specific standards
that they're absolutely
rocking and enrolling with.
So Kristen, I think to summarize,
this standards-based grading
thing can be very beneficial
to gifted students or to
high-achieving students,
because it provides
better information to them
and to their teachers
about where it is exactly
they're rocking and rolling.
And it frankly just
eliminates some busy work
that they may have been
subjected to in the past.
- Great, all right.
I'm gonna sneak in one more question here
before we close out.
So the other place that
I've been hearing a lot
about standards-based
grading is in conversations
around equity and in schools
that are serving students
from historically
under-resourced communities.
Tell me how you see standard-based grading
potentially helping those students.
- Yeah, there's plenty of
research that has been done
about the factors that teachers consider
in determining a grade.
And this is again, pre
standards-based grading.
And what we'll find in that research
is that often teachers consider
things like participation,
sometimes even attendance.
And what we know when we look at students
of different backgrounds
is that by grading
based upon participation and attendance,
that is a very inequitable
practice for some student groups.
I also think about, just to focus in
on a very specific practice
that I'm ashamed to say
that I did in my own classroom,
that's awarding extra credit points
for students bringing in materials,
such as Kleenex boxes
or whiteboard markers.
Think about the families
that are able to do that
and the families that
are not able to do that.
It's pretty obvious
that there are families
who are able to buy their kids' grades
or improve their kids' grades
by bringing in these materials.
And I think of course,
this is just a far out
over-exaggerated example, but this happens
to the point where there
was a legislator in Iowa
several years ago that proposed a law
to eliminate this practice
because of the very question
that you brought up, Kristen.
And so perhaps the
viewers and listeners here
that are thinking maybe
just a real small step
they consider, if we are to eliminate
the awarding of extra
credit for materials,
that's one step closer to more
equitable grading practices.
And if we want to eliminate
providing some points
in our classrooms for
participation or for attendance,
that would be another
great and wonderful step
we could do that is more
equitable for students
of different backgrounds and demographics.
So, yeah, and I'm just gonna
shout out to Joe Feldman,
who wrote a fantastic book
called "Grading for Equity"
that speaks even more
detail to this very topic,
and so we're hearing some
pretty big school districts
across the state saying we wanna make
some of these grading changes
because equity is our
driving force behind it.
I'm saddened to see that
that COVID-19 happened,
but in a way I'm pretty excited to know
that as a result of COVID-19 happening,
that more schools are recognizing
how to create and utilize
more equitable grading practices.
So thank you for bringing
that topic to light, Kristen.
- Absolutely.
Well, this 30 minutes has flown by.
It's been so nice talking to you.
Thank you for all the
research you're doing
and the work you're doing
to help schools and teachers
make this shift.
It's been a pleasure talking to you today.
- Thank you very much,
Kristen, for having me.
It's been a pleasure.
- Great, and thanks for everyone out there
who's been listening.
We will see you next time.